you said uh you know you were fat and
and now you look like you lost a lot of
weight you're in good health like uh I'm
doing real good right now yeah you had
uh like it was a public like like known
thing yeah the heart failure you had
like a real serious health scare [__]
yeah well you know to hear those words
heart failure is pretty heavy yeah you
know what I'm saying just those words
you could quote that anyway you want
those words put together in any
sentences like what the [__] you know so
it was shocking you know what I mean but
I started to notice that I was like um
uh losing my wind you know what I mean
like you know I'd be doing regular
things that I do but I'd be like winded
you know like twice I'm feeling twice as
winter like what the [__] you know what
I'm saying
so when I started getting worried about
it you know I went to the doctor and and
I think this is right before right at
the beginning of covet you know because
I remember the doctor couldn't come down
or no doctor I went to the hospital with
my brother to get it checked out and no
doctors were available because of covet
you know what I'm saying and it sounds
like you're describing symptoms of cobit
because it's a respiratory thing and he
can't breathe right yeah well I could
breathe like I was living with I was
living with with this you know I mean it
didn't happen like overnight where I'm
like why am I so winded you know what
I'm saying I noticed my wind wind
getting worse and I just assumed it was
um
I don't know what the [__] I hadn't been
on the road or something I don't know
you know what I'm saying but but um like
you're out of shape yeah you know but
then I was like this is something wrong
you know what I mean so yeah I've been
living with it you know so anyway when
anyway they ended up
um admitting me the next day and they
were like yeah you got heart uh
something heart failure congestive heart
failure yeah something like that and I
was like what does that mean they were
like your heart's beating irregularly
you know and they're like we're gonna
try to um uh shock it with the you know
and put it back it'll flip back you know
flip back in so they did that and it it
did they did it twice and then they're
like all right we gotta do this uh
procedure called a fibrillation you know
what I mean and they um
they did that right basically and um
I've been back to where I was before I
had heart failure ever since you know
what I mean and they're like it could
last like that
for who knows but it could stop at any
time you know what I'm saying well you
go back to what it was but I want to say
I want to say because right now I'm
totally where I've ever been before any
of that you know like I don't have an
irregular heartbeat but that could
change you know what I mean but they did
a procedure that stopped it you know
what I'm saying and um I want to say
that before I had that procedure though
we did two concerts you know what I mean
and and I paced myself you know what I
mean and I did it and they were telling
me you can you can live with it you just
gotta pace yourself you can't be out
here fighting you know what I'm saying
things like that like they were like you
can live with it you can you can you
know you just can't do like you used to
you'll get to know like when you start
losing your breath your skin be way
quicker than back in the day you know
before you had this did they say you you
had to rock it like fewer faga bottles
what was the cause of it did they tell
you what's the cause ah [__] man you
know I had I don't know
touring life huh just like being on tour
your whole life and I don't know I was
Heavy a lot overweight oh my God I was
Heavy bro like 450 pounds you know what
I mean like um did it run in the family
being heavy yeah well being heavy or
even heart problems no I don't know my
dad you know what I mean but um not in
my mom my mom my mom's still alive you
know what I mean
so um no I don't know but they were like
you know you can live a life but it's
it's it means you gotta step back and so
we were like why tour like we've always
been you know what I mean like like why
why go out and pawn a pigment like we
always been neither one of us like doing
it like that anyway you know what I mean
we you know like we would be totally on
the road constantly playing a lot of the
same venues in it we get except for the
time on stage of course the rest of it
sucked you know so we were like we were
like man we're just through the annual
events and so I announced it and that's
when it went everywhere you know what I
mean you and I have been in touch like
on a more like personal level like
checking in on each other like talking
about stuff that like you don't talk
about publicly right like net worths and
stuff
Ah that's so funny dude um but uh and
like I'm sensitive to what like you and
I have talked about that that you don't
necessarily put out there but I'm asking
you because we haven't been in contact
for a minute like how are you doing and
how is your health and what's going on
with you well you know man
um
I'm doing good man I've been you know I
went through [__] really epic [__]
roller coaster no man because it was
just
epic bomb after epic bomb you know what
I mean in my life like like two things
in my life collided like at the same
time you know what I'm saying and it was
just a [__] with the death yeah man
everything like that whole time like the
in and then you know coming out of that
my brother and and his girl that he had
been with who was working with us you
know what I mean for years like at like
eight or nine years or something like
that they were together and she was all
apart they split up you know what I'm
saying and she went legitimate crazy the
reason they split up is because I guess
you know allegedly
her medications or whatever she wasn't
taking them or something like that I
don't know I can't speak it's not I
don't that's just what my brother's very
elusive but anyway she went crazy though
like allegedly you know I watched it
right right but anyway and she went on
like the war pass saying craziness you
know it's we pretty much got over it all
though you get what I'm saying right but
all that [__] happened you know that she
that whole Factor was a small thing
after what I just gone through though
you know what I mean like I went through
like just multiple
um bad things coming you know boom boom
boom and um I know you know I never lost
nobody before you know what I'm saying
right and um
it's just you know there's no shortcut
right you know what I'm saying it's like
there's no trick you know what I'm
saying there's no way to get around it
just gotta wait it out of time you just
gotta let it roll you over you know you
can [__] run deny
try to go run around it
is nothing you know what I'm saying
until you just lay down and let it
[__] steamroll you you know what I'm
saying that's what it is man but but
where you're at now like here like
yeah man I mean no I'm all good man [__]
you know I went to a Trauma Center you
know what I'm saying it was like a rehab
and a Trauma Center in Florida it was it
was both actually was it like a mental
health sabbatical
no it was like uh
how do I deal with this you know and I'm
on drugs you know what I'm saying it was
it was awful you know what I'm saying it
was just like
too much you know what I'm saying yeah
because then like historically you've
not been like an alcohol and drugs kind
of guy no like that was that like when
that crept up like that wasn't your Mo
oh no for not for my whole life you know
what I mean and then like I mean not I
hadn't had a problem in my whole life
you get what I'm saying right and then
and then like it it kind of because that
wasn't your ammo when that was going on
like it was very like secretive yeah
right and so like that that's why I was
like being so careful to help you know I
want to say if you know like
it became secretive you know what I'm
saying I guess I guess you could say I
guess you could say the problem became
secretive you get what I'm saying right
because you got shame around like your
behavior and you didn't want to tell
anybody and it's kept growing and
growing
yeah like no but you know what I'm
saying it just became
um
a problem yeah you know what I'm saying
uh more you know it's weird because I
never actually felt like that you know
like I I I kind of escaped
feeling like it was I kind of escaped
ever dealing with my own guilt because I
never actually felt it was a problem you
know and maybe I'm stubborn or stupid
but I'm also when I put my mind to
something I've been successful you know
what I mean so for a long time I told
myself I could do that right you know
what I'm saying it's uh it's like when
an alcoholic
really gets bad that's when they start
sneaking drinks and hiding the fact that
they're drinking if I'm hearing what
you're saying like once it kind of
became a problem like you you had to be
secretive about it
and uh and then what I hear you saying
yeah like the most and dude people with
uh alcoholic addictive Tendencies tend
to be the most driven ambitious like
capable people like people who
absolutely succeeded in everything they
try to do but that alcoholism and
addiction is where that party stops I
was listening to an Andrew huberman
podcast and he was talking about
childhood trauma is is linked like the
more childhood trauma you have the more
successful a person usually becomes
because it's like they're just so
focused on like pleasing other people or
pleasing their father pleasing their
mother like they have to [__] get
this successful goal to like prove that
they're and so it's just it's linked
with childhood trauma on how successful
people are yeah I'm not trying to get to
get you all on blast on this but uh but
I'm assuming anything you want to talk
about bro honestly I I really don't care
like when I say that I mean of course I
care I I don't I'm not ashamed of
anything in my life and the um I want to
say this there's an art to not giving a
[__] okay it can be very very helpful
and when you genuinely don't give a [__]
you know what I'm saying and I think
about my life and my secrets and
everything going on in my life and I
think if the only thing I don't want
nobody seeing me doing is jacking off
well I'm feeling comfortable with that
you know what I'm saying that's the only
thing I wanna but other than that I
really don't give a [__] if a video came
out of me doing anything because I'm not
doing anything that I feel is hurtful to
anybody yeah or creepy
in my opinion because I'll say anything
I do yeah I don't have any secrets you
know what I'm saying that was like the
only one I had really was drugs you get
what I'm saying for that period of my
life and and other than that there's
nothing I'm I'm
regretful or guilty of that I do you
know what I mean that's good man and uh
but like with respect to all that like
uh you got your recovery on track yeah
man 100 bro damn I love that man no no I
give you my word though right like my
brother after all that I live with my
brother you know what I'm saying
my brother called Dr Drew Dr Drew was
the one that suggested the place I went
to you know what I'm saying the trauma
center and the rehab you know what I
mean so
they they set up a plan or something
because um I do random I piss random for
my brother you know what I mean good and
I said to my brother he's like listen
when we start doing these um tests on
don't give me no [__] no matter what
kind of [__] mood you're in you know
and I remember telling them when I when
I came out in uh
um January 1st I said um
I said there's nothing I want more than
to put 5 000 clean tests between this
time period I just got through in my
life and
gaining your [__] trust you
know what I'm saying sure so bring them
[__] on you know what I'm saying
that's good and that'll be time now like
my brother if he's slipping I'll be like
rob you want me to drop you know what I
mean he'd be like yeah you know what I
mean but it's random you know what I
mean he'll also come up knock on the
bedroom door you know what I mean when
I'm not thinking about it you know what
I mean and that's the [__] yeah you know
but I don't I don't have
um
urges anyway okay that's where I'm
blessed yeah I'm saying because I don't
it's just not something that haunts my
mind you know so I don't really that's
why I don't want to go to meetings and I
don't want to um uh um be you know I I
love the sobriety the community and
everything and it saved my life but the
reason I'm not active in it and I don't
want to go to meetings is I I the type
of person I am it's easy for me not to
remind myself of all that you know
because I don't think about it you get
what I'm saying and I think if I did
that I probably would you get what I
mean because I would start to think
about it more than I do and I don't you
know what I mean if that's working for
you yeah man if that if that's working
for you then that's all that matters oh
[__] yeah and and and if it does if it
stops working and you find yourself
going around the loop then you want to
look at because
no no yeah if even if I started to feel
that way yeah a lot of people have
reached out
the sober Community is massive it's way
bigger than people [__] think you
know what I'm saying yeah and and you
know like I'm part of that community and
I'm like hitting you up like hey man I
don't know what's going on dude people
genuinely [__] care you know what I'm
saying
um and when I say active is I mean going
to meetings and stuff you know it's
because you know
ah bless the Creator whoever is blessing
me I don't have those kind of urges you
know what I mean I don't I don't live
with that you know what I mean and uh if
I did I would [__] be doing something
about I would be doing something about
it you know what I mean like honestly
man it's just not it's not been an issue
for me and I'm so [__] grateful you
know you'd look great thanks man there
are like you look great you sound great
you
uh lost a lot of weight
do you like shopping on Amazon I do and
good news is Stevo's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
plus Stephen's butthole destroyer and
Stevo's butt wipes for your butthole
it's the butthole bundle available on
Amazon right now
yeah dude